Hello and welcome to fire learning.
Napoleon Bonaparte began as a course again,
man in the French army what would rise to become emperor of France and
subsequently one of the greatest military commanders in world history.
He extended his empire into a territory of the most powerful nations of the day
at times,
taking them all on at once and winning.
In this video,
we're going to look at 10 pieces of advice at the emperor gave throughout his
life that perhaps we could utilize.
These are of course the words of Napoleon.
I myself,
I'm not taking a side either way on them for the purposes of this video,
so let's get to it.
Number 10 never fight too much with one enemy or you will teach him your art of
war.
Napoleon had many enemies in the political arena and on the battlefield,
but he was not constantly at war with each one.
When you fight too often with your enemies,
they begin to understand your way of doing things which can hinder you greatly.
Napoleon further elaborated on his thinking and his life.
Sing is best to change your tactics to surprise your enemy.
Number nine,
impossible is a word only to be found in the dictionary of fools.
Napoleon was a self made man.
If there ever was a one coming from a small island which was barely French,
you rose to fight.
Revolution became a general in the French army,
then eventually would overthrow the revolution himself.
The plain spoke often about how his dedication and tactical thought brought him
to where he was.
He believed that nothing was impossible and ended up doing what others thought
was impossible.
This is perhaps the most powerful way of putting that thinking into words.
Number Eight,
power is in the appearance of power.
As Napoleon also said,
a throne is only a bench covered in velvet.
If you wish to maintain power,
you must have confidence in your ability to handle that power and display that
confidence to others so that they trust you.
Napoleon was only a man,
but he was emperor because this nation recognized them as such,
and he proved himself capable of the task.
Number seven,
victory belongs to the most persevering.
Napoleon knew how to get things done,
how to get to where he wanted to be and how to overcome seemingly insurmountable
challenges.
He was brilliant to be sure,
but that brilliance would have been wasted if he was not also a dedicated and
passionate workaholic.
Often in fact,
Napoleon had a desk placed next to his bed during his campaigns so that you
could wake up in the middle of the night and work his victories and it just fall
from the sky.
They were very hard.
One.
Number six,
take time to deliberate,
but when the time for action has come,
stop thinking and go in.
As with all great leaders,
Napoleon spent time putting thoughts into the dynamic of his empire.
However,
he was a man who knew when and how to act compared to him,
especially during his early rain.
His opponents often seems comparatively to stumble around and retaliation to his
quick efficiency.
Number five,
if you want something done right,
do it yourself.
Napoleon did not only know when to act,
but he generally had no problem getting right up into whatever he was doing.
This quote can be taken in a few ways.
Each of which she portrayed throughout his life during his early years as a
general fighting in Italy,
he earned the nickname,
the little corporal for fighting alongside his men at the battle of our coal
against Austria,
not so much for a size down.
Napoleon wasn't really short.
He was actually a five seven which was about average Thursday.
Later,
he lacked confidence as Marshall's government officials and average people and
often took control of what they were doing to improve upon it.
He would carry this mentality throughout his life.
Even at his last battle,
he intended to lead his old guard into battle before he was stopped by his
Marshall's.
And number four,
death is nothing but to live in Glorious and defeated is to die daily.
Napoleon believed that success and glory were so important that it was worth
risking your life for,
and he proved as a belief by in fact risking his life and everything he had many
times throughout his life.
He could have died and his bowels,
he could have been executed for his coup d'etat.
He could have easily lost many of his wars,
but he didn't.
He persevered and even though he was defeated in the end he won glory and
accomplished quite a bit.
Number three,
I am sometimes a fox in sometimes a lion.
The whole secret of government is knowing when to be,
which.
This was definitely true of Napoleon's modus operandi.
He was cunning,
secretive,
even sometimes deceitful,
but also bold,
daring and efficient.
He would at times makes sly moves against internal and external politicians of
his day and at others would straight forwardly do grandiose thinks like crowning
himself.
Emperor number two for hostile newspapers are to be feared more than a thousand
bayonets at.
This is a somewhat verbose way of saying the pen is mightier than the sword,
but Napoleon was not saying this as the underdog,
but rather someone who knew how important public opinion was in maintaining his
position.
Remember,
of course power is in the appearance of power.
Napoleon knew all too well that newspapers very strongly influenced what people
thought of him.
And so he in fact went so far as to take control and limit what the press could
say about him and his achievements.
Number one,
I have only one counsel for you,
the master.
It was not enough for Napoleon to get by.
He had to be the best at what he did.
He was not only a general,
he was one of the revolution's greatest if his enemies with bold and original
tactics.
He was not only the leader of France,
he was emperor and he was not satisfied with France alone,
and he set out to procure more lands and at his empire,
his height rural from Portugal to Poland.
Napoleon advises not settling the the master,
whatever it takes.
These are only 10 on the points,
pieces of advice.
He of course offers much more.
Well,
what do you think of these quotes?
Let me know in the comments section below.
For more videos like this and videos on many other subjects,
we should have checked out fire of learning and subscribe.
Thank you for watching.